thousands of years in the bank what
began as part of a religious festival
honoring the Greek god Zeus in the rural
Greek town of Bolivia as today become
the greatest show of sporting excellence
on earth the inception date in 776 BC
became the basis for the Greeks earliest
calendar where time was marked in four
year increments called Olympiads what
could it be
why it's the Olympic Games of course
competition Foster's excellence or so
thought the ancient Greeks in addition
to sporting events contests were held
for music singing and poetry you can
read about them all yourself in
classical literary works like Homer's
Iliad and Virgil's Aeneid even mythical
heroes appreciate a good contest every
now and then wouldn't you say for the
first 13 games the ancient Greek
Olympics featured just one event the
200-yard - but over time new exciting
contests like boxing chariot annual
racing
enticed many hopeful champions into the
other big stadium the combined running
jumping Presley gentleman throwing and
Earling the discus events known as the
pentathlon inspired world-class
competition and the tank Rati on a
no-holds-barred fight we're only
fighting an eye gouging and prohibited
ensured the toughest men were victorious
and victorious they were nobody tops the
local Baker choroid us who in 776 BC
became the very first Olympic champion
and we'll never forget more surface of
beggar I the 720 BC Olympic victor tore
away his loincloth so he could race
unimpeded inaugurating the ancient Greek
tradition of competing in the known now
there's a winning streak if ever
we've seen one but all good things must
end in 391 ad the Christian Roman
Emperor Theodosius and pagan practices
so the world soon bid a fond farewell to
the Olympic Games but just like those
early Pankratz young athletes you can't
keep a good one down and 1500 years
later in 1896 the modern Olympic Games
kicked off in Athens Greece today the
summer and winter olympics bring
international world-class athletes
together by the thousands uniting fans
by the billions for the world's foremost
sporting competition
citius Altius Fortius three cheers for
the Olympics